the anti-defamation league and paypal
partnered to crack down on
extremism with daily death rates from
covet now lower than death rates from
alzheimer's the media and democrats push
the panic button
and we examine who's really skipping the
vaccination i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench hero show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben remember that time when the biden
administration said that inflation was
transitory
and then it just kept rising and now
they're saying well it might not be
super transitory
here's the thing guys you should
diversify into something that is not
controlled by the federal government i'm
talking of course about diversifying
into precious metals this is the time to
declare your independence for your
savings cut your ties see the
staller invest in gold and silver with
my friends at birch gold group if you
haven't reached out to birch gold to
diversify part of your ira or 401k into
a precious metals ira
do it today text ben 247 4747 get a free
information kit
i'm protecting your savings with gold i
buy my gold from birch gold they've got
an a plus rating with the better
business bureau countless
five star reviews over 10 000 happy
customers talk to them
have them help you safeguard your
investments text ben
247 4747 to claim your free information
kit and to speak with a precious metals
expert on holding gold and silver
in a tax sheltered account again text my
name ben to 47 47 47
to get started protect your savings
today with the folks i trust over at
birch
gold text my name ben 247 47 47
and claim that free information kit
today okay well
quick announcement my new book the
authoritarian moment is now out you can
go purchase it right now
at any bookstore or online go check it
out the reason being
it is quite prescient okay and today's
today's story from the authoritarian
front lines this is an insane story but
this
is the way the country is going to go
neutral service providers
these are places that just used to
provide you services this is how you
think
of most of the businesses with which you
engage in everyday life your insurance
company is a neutral service provider it
is supposed to provide you service
regardless of race
religion or creed your supermarket a
neutral service provider
and your credit card company is also
supposed to be a neutral service
provider well certainly paypal which is
a payment service right you use paypal
to pay your bills that's supposed to be
a neutral service provider but one of
the things that we have seen
from an increasingly authoritarian left
is the attempt to use
all of these neutral service providers
as bottlenecks
that restrict your ability to speak
freely as ways to crack down
on the undesirables in the opinion
community we've seen this before we've
seen
credit card companies for example say
that you're not allowed to use their
credit cards in order to purchase guns
right this has become a major issue in
the united states you've also seen
places like amazon web services d
platform parlor amazon web services is a
neutral service provider
in the aftermath of january 6th you saw
amazon web services
at the behest of democrats crack down on
parlor and kick it off its platform it
was removed from google
it was removed from apple store it was
removed nearly everywhere by the tech
companies
again all of which were supposed to be
neutral service providers
this is the big debate over big tech big
tech facebook is supposed to be a
neutral service provider it is not
supposed to crack down on you
on the basis of your ideology now there
are folks on the left who suddenly
become free market libertarians when it
comes to the stuff
treating neutral service providers as
though they are basically the daily wire
right they can make whatever call they
want about what content they can and
cannot engage in
and technically that's true these are
not government agencies but when you
have neutral service providers that
overtly decide they're going to crack
down on particular points of view this
is very bad for the country and we are
allowed to point out
that this is very bad for the country
especially because
we do have anti-discrimination law in
this country it applies to race
it applies to religion it now applies to
sexual orientation the one thing it does
not apply to is politics
right neutral service providers
generally are allowed to deny you
service on the basis of your politics
the problem is of course the left has
politicized every single
thing right everything is political so
if you say if you're if you're
a baker you say i don't want to bake
this cake for this same-sex wedding
they'll say
you are doing this not on the basis of
politics you're doing this not on the
basis of world view you're doing this on
the basis of animus
but if a baker says i'm not going to
bake a cake
for your biblical party then the idea is
that's politics
so everything that the left wants to
censor goes in the politics basket
and everything that the left wants to
force you to do goes
in the immutable characteristic basket
that you're not allowed to discriminate
against so the left's categories break
down into
the stuff you're not allowed to
discriminate against and the stuff you
are allowed to discriminate against
everything
that is remotely conservative goes in
the things you're allowed to
discriminate against basket everything
else goes into things you're not allowed
to discriminate against basket so when
we talk about neutral service providers
increasingly
neutral service providers will not
discriminate on the basis of anything
except for conservative politics okay
this is why the story that is now coming
out about paypal and the anti-defamation
league
is scary so the anti-defamation league
used to be
a much more bipartisan it was always a
left-leaning organization but sort of a
bipartisan organization
largely focused on fighting
anti-semitism that was broadened now to
include discrimination
of all sorts now the anti-defamation
league is basically a democratic front
group unfortunately the anti-defamation
league
in the aftermath of abe foxman's
retirement has basically become
a a sort of talking points organization
for the left
in a similar way to the southern poverty
law center right the basic idea of the
adl
is that you have to focus deeply in any
time there is a republican who does
something anti-semitic this is
worthy of unending scorn and ridicule
fair enough
but if you've got the squad in the
democratic party saying overtly
anti-semitic stuff for years on end this
is stuff that requires maybe a little
bit of
tutting but at that point you sort of
let it go in any case the
anti-defamation league
is now working with paypal a neutral a
neutral service provider
in order to crack down on content and
they say that they're cracking down on
extremist content
the problem of course is that the left
has a really really bad habit and that
habit is conflating everything they
don't like with extremist content
in the same way that the january 6
commission is largely going to be about
conflating all republican and
conservative ideology with january 6th
and saying that if you supported donald
trump in 2020 it's because you wanted
january 6th to happen
or by the way even if you thought that
the election was decided by fraud
that that makes you a january 6
compatriot okay like i don't agree that
that november 4th was decided by fraud i
think that trump lost the election
but there is even a distinction between
the people who went and protested that
day and the people who actually
committed the criminal act of going
onto the capitol grounds breaking in and
threatening people okay but the left
wants to wrap all of this up in a ball
in the same way what the what the left
would like to do is broaden out the
rubric of extremism dangerous
speech dangerous incitement to include
pretty much everybody on the right and
now they're going to weaponize
neutral service providers in order to
basically excise you
from the community of people who get to
participate
in the services of a neutral service
provider so according to the
anti-defamation league here is their
here's their press release yesterday and
this is dangerous dangerous stuff
because this is going to be the model
going forward
you've seen this increasingly
advertisers are being told you can
advertise with msnbc you can't advertise
with fox news
you have democrats who are openly
pushing the fcc
to crack down on dissemination of
channels like fox news you saw npr last
week
trying to push facebook to d platform
daily wire
for no reason other than more
conservative right they said we don't
lie they said that we don't
engage in conspiracy theories they say
that we're openly conservative and we
should be suppressed anyway
the goal here is to take businesses
again which are not subject to first
amendment restrictions because they're
businesses
and through both governmental and social
pressure get them to bottleneck free
speech
that's the goal here so here's the adls
press release quote paypal holdings in
partnership
with adl today announced a new
partnership initiative to fight
extremism and hate
through the financial industry and
across at-risk communities this is the
latest effort by paypal in combating
racism
hate and extremism across its platforms
and the industry
through this collaboration paypal and
adl have launched a research effort to
address the urgent need
to understand how extremism and hate
movements throughout the united states
are attempting to leverage financial
platforms
to fund criminal activity okay so if
we're talking about how paypal
should not be engaged in criminal
activity or should be restricting
its ability to restricting the ability
of people to use their platform to
engage in criminal activity fine
we have those sorts of regulations with
regard to all sorts of financial
transactions we have those regulations
put in place many of them directly after
9 11
this is why if you're transferring over
10 000 for example
you need to have basically a delay and
the federal government checks into it
and all of that
but that's not the entirety of what
paypal and the and the adl are doing
according to aaron
karsmer the chief risk officer and evp
of risk and platforms and paypal quote
by identifying partners across sectors
with common goals and complementary
resources we can make an even greater
impact than any of us could do on our
own
we're excited to partner with the adl
other nonprofits and law enforcement in
our fight against hate in all of its
forms so first of all i am
very uneasy with the with the rubric of
quote hate in all of its forms
because as we have seen many on the left
perceive anything on the right to be
hateful that they disagree with
right if you believe for example that
men are men and women are women this
means that you're a hate monger
according to the left and you should be
suppressed so i have some real
difficulty
in the language here if they want to say
we're cracking down on criminality
that's not even worthy of a press
release
right that's what you should be doing
businesses should of course always be
fighting criminality and illegality but
that's not what we're talking about here
as becomes pretty clear as this press
release goes on
the initiative with paypal will be led
through adl's center on extremism a
leading authority on extremism terrorism
and hate
paypal and adl will focus on uncovering
and disrupting the financial pipelines
that support extremist and hate
movements
in addition to extremist and
anti-government organizations the
initiative will focus here we go
the initiative will focus on actors and
networks spreading and profiting from
all forms of hate and bigotry against
any community
now we're getting kind of broad aren't
we we went from people engaging in
criminal activity
or people associated with criminal
organizations to focusing on quote
actors and networks
spreading and profiting from all forms
of hate and bigotry against any
community
now again this makes me very uneasy
because i do not think that the left is
a
particularly circumspect in how they
approach questions of hate and bigotry
as we have seen the president of the
united states
this daughtering old quote-unquote
moderate has spent the last several
months declaring that if you're in favor
of voter id it's because you're akin to
a jim crow racist
so no i don't think that the adl has any
monopoly
on defining hate and bigotry i think the
left has a horrific habit
of declaring everyone they dislike a
hateful bigot
and i don't think they have any
restrictive principles here at all so
you put that on top of paypal
and now paypal says okay well you want
to subscribe to daily wire or you want
to subscribe to
daily caller or you want to subscribe to
fox nation well you know what they've
been doing over there
tucker carlson white supremacist ben
shapiro hate monger
well i guess we can't use your your
platform anymore in order to pay like
you can see where this is going and it
is nowhere good
again if you are attempting to crack
down on criminal activity i got no
problem at all
the nice thing about criminal activity
is to bright line because criminal
activity
has statutorily defined terms that is
not the case with hate
and bigotry it's why we don't prosecute
hate and bigotry in the united states
the way they attempt to
in europe or canada which is a very good
thing we should not prosecute hate and
bigotry in the united states because it
is a fungible term
it is an empty vessel that you can fill
with anyone you don't like
jonathan greenblatt the ceo of the adl
says quote all of us including in the
private sector have a critical role to
play
in fighting the spread of extremism and
hate with this new initiative we're
setting a new standard for companies to
bring their expertise to critical social
issues
we have a unique opportunity to further
understand how hate spreads
and develop key insights that will
inform the efforts of the financial
industry
law enforcement and our communities in
mitigating extremist
threats according to the press release
paypal and adl will work closely with
organizations like the united
latin american centers to protect
marginalized communities against
extremism
they will work closely with them to
share trends and hate with marginalized
and vulnerable communities
and with the goal of helping to empower
and safeguard those communities which
are frequently
targets of hate groups and extremist
acts
so you can see how this is going to
bleed from here's a group that
participates in criminal activity we
should crack down on that too
here are the kinds of people that
members of this group might like to
watch
and let's stop them and you can no
longer patronize those sites
the militarization of neutral service
providers in order to avoid the
structures of the first amendment
is a deep and abiding problem in
american life there are only two
possible remedies
one is actual regulation that adds
discrimination on the basis of politics
to anti-discrimination law which i think
the way a lot of
states are going to go now that we've
created a whole rubric of
anti-discrimination law
much of which is in violation of basic
first amendment principles by the way
right you can be against discrimination
and also recognize that
anti-discrimination law
really really impedes on freedom of
association as well as freedom of speech
and both things can be true at once that
racism is terrible and also in the
united states you do have a right to say
racist things
both of those things can be true at once
in the same way that in the united
states
i think pornography is terrible and
still the supreme court has declared
that you have the right to buy
pornography if you're an adult
right just because there is a quote
unquote
right to do something does not mean that
you always approve of the use of the
right
however if we are going to have an
anti-discrimination rubric in the united
states
and we are going to say it's not okay to
discriminate against people on the basis
of everything
from identifying as a member of the
opposite sex to race like that entire
broad spectrum
then the notion the only people who can
be discriminated against are white
conservatives uh seems to be a bit of a
problem you're gonna see states fight
back against that
that's one possibility the other is
we're just gonna get two separate sets
of
service providers one for conservatives
and one for liberals and listen
we here on the right i'm happy to make
money off of that you know because if
there if there's going to be a right
wing paypal i'm happy to found it
and i'm happy to have people use it it's
fine with me i'll make a lot of money
it is horrible for the country as
neutral spaces disappear
we have no relationship with the people
who live next door to us and that means
this the further polarization and split
in the country all of which i talk about
in the new book the authoritarian moment
but
it is a deep problem it's getting worse
every single day already in just one
second
we're going to talk about the new covet
cram down because the the amount of
panic that is being evidenced by the
media
over what's going on with the delta
variant is wildly out of proportion with
the actual facts i'm going to show you
some stats that
people apparently don't care about and
it's
pretty alarming how insane people have
gotten about this we'll get to that in
one second first
there are a thousand reasons why
protecting my home matters to me
if somebody stops by or something is
going on i know that ring will let me
know and that's great i've got three
little kids
running around sometimes you're outside
you turn around
and you're five-year-old's gone they're
like uh-oh where'd my five-year-old go
good news pull up the phone boom i've
got the ring app i know exactly where my
five-year-old is
he's in the other room making trouble
ring has a special offer right now go to
ring
dot com forward slash ben it's the
perfect way to start your ring
experience with ring's home security
system when anyone stops by or you send
something going on outdoors around the
house you know ring has every corner of
your home covered
one of the best benefits you install the
products yourself the whole process is
hassle free your whole home is protected
with easy to install indoor and outdoor
cams
and the cams work seamlessly with ring
alarm you see what's happening from
anywhere all in one very simple app when
my wife and i are out of town we want to
keep an eye on the kids
we pull up the ring app and we know
exactly what is going on it is peace of
mind for both me and my wife protect
your home anytime
from anywhere with ring alarm go to
ring.com ben
for a special offer on a ring alarm
security kit today you can build the
system that's right for your home have
it up and running in minutes that's
ring.com
again ring dot com slash ben alrighty so
let's talk about the current covet power
grab and at this point
it is an endless power grab because the
stats just do not back the idea that we
should be
putting mandatory masking
provisions in place or that on a broad
scale we should be
mandating that every single human get
the vaccine i think there are certain
situations in which businesses
have some fairly good reasons to mandate
that their employees get the vaccine i
think that is basically restricted in my
opinion
to health care providers if you're
working at a hospital you're dealing
every day every single day
with people with unique vulnerabilities
many of whom could not get the vaccine
the idea that you should not be a vector
of transmission if you're going to work
at the hospital that makes some sense to
me but we're going way beyond that so
first of all let's start with what is
the situation with covert right now
because i'm going to show you the actual
charts that apparently nobody wants to
show you it's unbelievable that nobody
wants to show you these charts
okay so let's begin with deaths in the
united states
from covid 19. okay so first
what is the seven day rolling average so
according
this according to the new york times by
the way these stats are from the new
york times the seven day rolling average
as of yesterday
of deaths in the united states from
covet 19 was 269.
so let's put that by way of contrast
every day in the united states from
alzheimer's about 330 people die
every day about 1800 people in the
united states die of heart disease
at the height of the pandemic in excess
of 4 000 people
were dying a day from covet so we are
down by a factor of somewhere between
10 and 20 in terms of how many people
are dying
per day from covid and that that
should not be an alarming stat to you i
mean
if you are alarmed by the fact that 270
people a day are dying of covet to the
point where you're talking about
nationwide mass mandates lock it all
down don't go back to work
i don't know what to tell you you've
lost the thread you can look at this
chart just
graphically you can look at the chart
that i'm looking at right now we are now
at the lowest rate of death
that we have been since literally the
beginning of the pandemic
right even in the middle of last summer
when we had that bit of a lull we
weren't down to the seven day rolling
average
okay that's for the united states more
broadly okay how about some of the
specific states that are now considering
more lockdowns
let's start with new york here is the
case average from new york
back at the height of the pandemic in
new york you saw this around the
beginning of the year you were seeing
over 15 000 cases a day diagnosed
in new york state the seven-day rolling
average of cases diagnosed in new york
state
is now about 1 500. okay so they are
down by again
a factor of 10 over 10.
okay so that is um that is good i mean
that's good
what's even more good is the fact that
as there's an increase in cases
we have not seen a consummate increase
in deaths
okay here is deaths from new york the
seven day rolling average of deaths in
the entire state of new york
a state of about 19 million people the
average
deaths in new york again these are new
york times stats
five the seven day rolling average five
deaths a day
from coven and we're talking now about
mass mandates and about state employee
mandates five deaths five okay i can
count them literally on a hand
five that's how many fingers i have
incredibly enough
okay uh the new york times reports that
as of july 25th there were nine deaths
in new york
from there there were you can see the
chart you can see
okay last year at the worst of the
pandemic in new york
when the thing was first starting you
were seeing a thousand deaths a day
you are down to five in new york count
them
five in the entire state of new york
okay so you saw the case rate going up
right again you can look at the death
deaths are not mirroring the case rate
we have now disconnected the case rate
from the deaths
which was the point of the vaccine we
have been successful
you would think now would be a great
time to declare victory democrats can't
do it
let's take a look at florida so florida
is of course the worst state in america
terrible horrible oh my god florida oh
no
horrible okay so florida is seeing a
radical uptick in the number of
diagnosed cases
the cases are being diagnosed largely
among people who are younger
and healthier because all the olds in
florida already got the vaccine
my parents are 65 they got the vaccine
everyone they know had the vaccine
hey if you come to our offices
apparently i'm the only one who got the
vaccine because the only people
who got the vaccine are people who felt
themselves to be particularly vulnerable
now do i think that's good logic
no i got the vaccine my wife got the
vaccine we're both young we're both
healthy thank god
but here's the thing so florida right
now is being just clubbed about the ears
by me look at florida
my god look at the number of cases being
diagnosed in florida
oh my the whole rhonda's death scientist
and the seven-day rolling average of new
cases
is about 10 500 in the in the
state of florida okay which we are now
approaching
levels that were about what it was the
height of the pandemic right which is in
january we're seeing about
15 000 new cases a day okay so you are
seeing a radical increasing case rate
in florida now let's look at deaths in
florida
the death's in florida i'm sorry like
you're treating this as a cri like okay
so over the weekend my kids got a cold
i have a little bit of cold right now is
this a public health crisis
no because none of us are going to die
from the cold diagnosis of a condition
if you don't die and you don't get
seriously ill is not a public health
crisis
okay so what is the seven day rolling
average in the state of florida
again according to the new york times
the seven day rolling average of death
in the state of florida is
39 39 and it has not risen
it's actually been on the decline since
approximately mid-april
basically since the vaccines started to
go out at the height of the pandemic
in january you were seeing sometimes in
excess of 200 death today
so we are down from the height of the
pandemic in florida
from well over 200 deaths today to 39
deaths a day and yet this is considered
39 and
by the way there are 21 million people
who live in florida
i'm sorry this is not a public health
crisis any longer it is not
that doesn't mean on an individual level
that if you get if you're unvaccinated
you don't have risk factors certainly
you do it does mean that the job of the
government here the sort of panic of the
government is unjustified let's look
quickly
at the cases from california okay
quickly the case is from california
you can see that they are rising
okay and they're rising fairly steadily
they're up to about 3 000 cases a day
their seven-day rolling average is like
6 400 cases in a day at the height of
the pandemic in california
there were 42 000 cases a day 17 40 and
50 000 cases a day so now they're about
like 6 000 so they're way down
how about their deaths where are they in
california in terms of deaths
they are down at approximately 20 their
seven day rolling averages
20 deaths they were in excess well in
excess of 500 deaths a day at the height
of the pandemic
so does any of this justify all of the
lockdown talk and the
masking talk and the panic talk of
course it doesn't
none of this justifies that okay so
those are the stats i just gave them to
you those are more stats than the media
apparently are going to give you they
give you
fact like they give you facts without
any level of context
you know if fact checkers had any brains
in their head that's the context they
would check
but wow look at that the case rate in in
california is up 40
over over yeah what's the death rate
like well look at that the death rate's
up 40
oh you mean it went from like two to
three like
well done guys okay so let's talk for a
second about who is not getting
vaccinated
because the narrative is it's all the
trump supporters the evil evil trump
supporters and the reason
that this narrative has been drawn by
the left is because this is about the
blaming game at this point
see here's the thing the rationale for
control is now gone
we had emergency protocols that were
taken last year and
the thing about members of the
government is they love emergency
protocols it is their favorite thing in
all of the land they
love it when there's an emergency and
then they get to declare unilateral
power
this is considered an unending good
and the best way to declare unending
power is declare a never-ending crisis
it's to say the crisis is not over until
everyone can walk outside
in the free air regardless of vaccinated
or unvaccinated status
and not have to worry about covid at all
zero covid
now no one in the scientific community
seriously thought zero covert was a real
goal
no one thought that no one of any
serious bent of mind thought that was
the case
as i've said 1 000 times at the very
beginning of the pandemic the goal was
don't swamp the hospitals then it became
wait till the vaccine gets out there
then it was
make sure that everybody has the option
to get the vaccine we're there it's over
if you don't get the vaccine on you if
you do get the vaccine good for you
we're done okay the public health requi
the involvement of the public health
authorities in preventing the
transmission
of a disease from for example a
vaccinated person to a person who
voluntarily decided not to get
vaccinated
this does not involve the government and
it should not involve the government at
this point
but the media have to come up with a
rationale for why the pandemic is not
over see here's the thing
i believe the pandemic for all public
health purposes
it's not over in the sense it's that
covet isn't killing people it's 100
killing people but
from the perspective of government the
job of government is now done
it is over the government has done what
it was supposed to do it mobilized
it provided the vaccine in record time
in terms of the it was actually private
industry that did that but it subsidized
that
it transferred out now the government
has no more job here and now the
emergency powers recede
just as in a war when the war is over
that doesn't mean there aren't still
soldiers overseas there are
it does mean that the wartime powers of
the government recede with it
but because the democrats last year
declared that there were only two ways
to view the pandemic one was
the evil people wanted to live with the
disease and the good people
the morally righteous and pure people
they wanted zero coveted
this meant that if you were not morally
righteous you wanted to kill grandmother
right this meant that if you said you
know younger people may have to go back
to work and grandma may have to lock
down until we have a vaccine this meant
that you were evil and bad
well now democrats have to come around
to the reality which is that
all the people who said we're gonna have
to learn to live with this were correct
all of those people were right rhonda
sanchez was right
sweden was right right the basic idea
which is that in the future you are
going to have to protect the most
vulnerable and allow everybody else to
live their life
all of those people were correct and the
stats are showing that they were correct
but instead of just going back and
saying you know what
that's right we really shouldn't go back
to lockdown policies we really shouldn't
be trying to
cram down on individuals violations of
their freedom
in defiance of the science by the way we
shouldn't instead the left has declared
that the pandemic
isn't over because again defining the
pandemic is over means their powers go
away and it means they're wrong last
year so instead they have to say
no the pandemic is still ongoing and the
reason it's ongoing can't be our
incompetence because we're the ones
in charge we did a great job it's you it
is you the trump supporters who did this
well there's only one problem with this
the real problem with the unvaccinated
in the united states
is generally not trump supporters the
real problem with the unvaccinated in
the united states
are people who are living in blue cities
okay the the major upticks that you are
seeing in the united states as always
in terms of vast death tend to be in
highly populated areas
because when it comes to communicable
diseases if you are in close proximity
to a lot of other people
you tend to transmit the virus more you
tend to get the virus more
if bob out in the boonies of wyoming is
living by himself on a ranch and doesn't
get the vaccine that affects no one
because he sees one person at the feed
store every week
if you are working in the healthcare
system in new york and you see lots of
people
and you don't have the vaccine you are a
more dangerous threat to others
in terms of transmitting the virus than
bob in wyoming who voted for trump
and this is the part the media just
don't want to cover because according to
the media again
it's all the right wingers right gavin
newsom the governor of california has
come up with this right he says well you
know
it's the right the evil right if only
the right would just get vaccinated all
this would be over here's gavin newsom a
terrible governor of california
those 25 that have remained unvaccinated
what do you attribute that to in your
state
well overwhelming majority of
misinformation by right wing
punishments period full stop time to be
a little bit more specific
the ron johnsons of the world the margie
trailer greens of the world the tucker
carlson's the world
i watch them i listen i pay attention
they're misinforming people
they're literally putting people's lives
at risk people are dying
because of the misinformation either
knowingly or unknowingly regardless
time to call it out okay so there's only
one problem with this theory right it
says that all the trump supporters all
the tucker carlson watchers
by the way tucker has a really popular
show four million people tonight three
and a half million people tonight watch
that show
um they're literally 40 of the
population of a 330 million country
aren't vaccinated at this point
including
tens of millions of adults tucker's
audience is like 4 million people so no
also who actually is unvaccinated so jim
garrity
points out that the people are largely
unvaccinated
in terms of the dangers that are being
provided are people in big cities
a gym guarantee of national review okay
for example as of this weekend
41 of new york city residents were not
vaccinated
probably they're all trump supporters
right trump won 22 of the vote in new
york city
total 41 of new york city residents
are not vaccinated who do you think is
providing more of a danger for
transmission
bob at the feed store in wyoming a
totally red state
or jill in new york city who has a woo
perspective on vaccines and and decided
not to get vaccinated
like 40 of her compatriots in new york
city in chicago
43 of residents are not vaccinated
trump carried 24 percent of the vote in
all of cook county
by the way less of the vote in chicago
proper 43
of the residents see you notice that the
media have completely ignored the fact
that there's a vast racial gap
in the amount of vaccination being done
basically it goes like this asians are
getting
vaccinated very high rate whites are
getting vaccinated at the next highest
rate
and then it goes i believe hispanics and
blacks and native americans
okay they don't want to talk about that
because according to the left if you're
black and you don't get vaccinated
that's because
you recall the evils of the tuskegee
experiments but if you're white you're
not getting vaccinated because you're an
evil tucker carlson supporter
whatever the rationale the people who
are not getting vaccinated in the big
cities are not
trump supporters which bespeaks
why people are not getting vaccinated
which we'll get to in a minute but again
the baseline notion that the media have
tried it out there in their dichotomous
view of the world is that every person
who's not getting vaccinated the great
evils out there it is all because of the
right-wing misinformation
everybody's getting vaccinated is a good
little biden voter that's not true
okay it's not true so we now have a
couple of untruths one that this
pandemic still requires massive
government
government's intervention it does not
and two that the people who are not
getting vaccinated and must be cuddled
into getting vaccinated are people who
are trump supporters
and this means we have to stifle
misinformation et cetera et cetera the
people who are not getting vaccinated
in blue states and in big cities all
over the place even in red states in big
cities
are generally not trump supporters in
l.a county only 30 percent of residents
are vaccinated
trump won 26 of the vote in 2020
of la county so gavin newsom goes on tv
and he's asked why aren't people getting
vaccinated and gavin newsom that dolt
his answer is well it's because they're
all watching tucker
really does tucker have huge audiences
in l.a county that i missed
again i disagree with a lot of what
tucker like i am i don't know how many
times i have to say this i am the most
pro-vaccine person on the right
okay i love the vaccines i think they're
a medical miracle i think they're
incredible
i got it my wife got i've been sick and
i've been utterly consistent on this
i've said this since the very beginning
of the pandemic
vaccines are i've been pro-vaccine since
before vaccine and non-veg
since that was that was a cool topic of
conversation right i've been very pro
vaccine for a very long time
l.a county is not a hotbed of right-wing
activity maricopa county arizona
which includes phoenix 52 of the
residents are not vaccinated trump only
won 48
of the vote there in 2020. in harris
county texas which includes houston
48 are not vaccinated trump only won 43
of that county
in philadelphia 37 of the residents are
unvaccinated
trump won a grand total of 17.9
of the vote there in 2020. in multnomah
county
under 63 percent have at least one dose
so 37
are unvaccinated trump won 18 of that
county in 2020. now you can go on this
all day
the notion that the only people who are
unvaccinated in the united states are
evil trump supporters is just a lie
and by the way in new york it gets even
worse according to garrity
after seven months forty percent of new
york city educators are not vaccinated
so remember all of those teachers were
like we can never go back to school
because there's a danger to us it's so
dangerous man it's dangerous
none of those teachers are bothering to
get vaccinated apparently
only 60 percent have gotten vaccinated
hey this is from the new york city
mayor's office the mta and the
department of corrections in your post
the percentage of new york city workers
who have been vaccinated
by their various agencies in new york
okay only 60 percent of teachers in the
department of education
have been vaccinated only 43 percent of
nypd has been vaccinated
only 51 of the fire department in new
york city
has been vaccinated most shockingly i
mean it's unbelievable
only 60 of new york city health and
hospitals has been vaccinated which is
nuts new york was the epicenter of this
thing you would figure that if people
in the hospitals saw you know freezer or
trucks filled with bodies stacked
outside that might get them vaccinated
apparently not
four in 10 people working for new york
health and hospitals have decided not to
get vaccinated
in the department of corrections only 42
percent of people are vaccinated despite
the fact that jails are hot spots and in
the mta
only 65 percent of workers are
vaccinated
apparently all right wingers all right
wingers right because it is very very
important is deeply important
that we have this manichaean view of
exactly
how vaccination works and how it does
not work here's gavin newsom again
comparing the unvaccinated to drunk
drivers
which is pretty crazy considering that
the difference between
like if you are a drunk driver you drink
and then the externality is you hit
somebody else and you kill them
if you are unvaccinated it's it's
actually more as though if you're going
to compare the unvaccinated and drunk
drivers which is an insulting and silly
comparison
if you're going to make that comparison
it's like saying that only drunk drivers
are on the road with each other
right because the vaccinated are
protected that's what vaccines do
here is gavin newsom again doing the
moral
high horse routine after going to the
french laundry and enjoying himself in
the middle of the pandemic
we don't even have to have that debate
if we can just get everybody vaccinated
that's not
vaccinated that's refusing to get
vaccinated this living
uh vaccine free and impacting the rest
of us it's like drunk drivers you don't
have the right to go out and drink and
drive and put everybody else at risk
including your own life at risk
california is one of the highest
vaccination rates in america
but yet we're still seeing an increase
because so many people 25
in california are refusing to get
vaccinated
okay it's just it's an incredible thing
it's incredible so here's the real
question
why is there no trust right so i'm
saying that it's not
you know just the right wing
misinformation and the anti-vax
stuff and all that it's not just that
there's a systemic problem with
institutional trust in america the same
people who are on tv yelling at you that
you need to get the vaccine
you don't trust and the reason you don't
trust them is because they have been
lying to you
it's amazing all these people they they
never have a moment where they look in
the mirror and they're like
why isn't anyone listening to me about
the vaccine it's all every
everything in public life right now is
principal skinner from the simpsons
saying is it me it can't be me it's the
children who are wrong
always and forever they're all principal
skinner it's the children who are wrong
maybe it's you maybe it's you guys we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about your lack of energy so
you know if you're like me
you lead a very busy life you've got a
lot going on you got kids you're running
after them all day
you need a boost of energy it can be
overwhelming to perform at your best
as you age yeah career you got family
trying to stay in shape life can get
stressful
you start to slow down you're not
present when you want to be to perform
at your best physically and mentally you
can't let age
beat you this is where m drive can help
m drive is the daily supplement for
driven men who don't want to slow down
who refuse to be tired every day who
want to be the best at what they do
it is packed with clinically tested
ingredients that support healthy
testosterone levels while helping you
lose weight and stay lean
added vitamins and nutrients reduce
stress and boost your drive so you can
perform
at your best find it at walgreens and
other retailers or visit mdrive4men.com
get 20
off your first order with promo code ben
they have free shipping and a 60 day
money back guarantee so you've got
nothing to lose m drive is not for
everyone
it is for the driven mdrive4men.com
use promo code ben get you that boost
that you need m drive
for men.com get 20 off your first order
with promo code ben
free shipping 60 day money back
guarantee nothing to lose
mdriveforman.com promo code
ben now guys reminder i have some
unbelievably exciting news for you today
my newest book the authoritarian moment
it is on bookshelves
today yes today is the big day i've been
awaiting it for months
honestly i wish this book had come out
three months ago four months ago like
right when i finished it but it is
immediate
and it is a it is a necessary read
especially if you want to fight back
against
the creeping authoritarianism you see
all around you in the institutions i
will be doing
a live stream book signing tonight this
very evening
7 30 p.m eastern 6 30 p.m central at
dailywire.com
ben shapiro youtube and ben shapiro
facebook so if you'd like to add this
newest book to your autographed
collection
go to dailywire.com get yourself a copy
right now for only 30 bucks that's a
pretty good deal if you ask me i mean 30
bucks for a keepsake you can hand on
your grandchildren
especially because when you purchase the
signed book you will be given the chance
to submit a question
for me to answer on tonight's live at
signing here's how it works when you
purchase your signed copy you'll be
asked to type in a question at checkout
then you can catch tonight's live
signing see if i answer your question
watch me sign your very book
if i don't get your question don't worry
you'll still get your signed copy so
what exactly are you waiting for add to
your collection by going to
dailywire.com right now
tune in tonight to watch that's 7 30 p.m
eastern 6 30 p.m central over at
dailywire.com
ben shapiro youtube and ben shapiro
facebook and mark your calendars because
tomorrow we'll be doing an episode of
backstage with special guest candace
owens we'll be discussing how communism
keeps trying to work its way into
american society you're not going to
want to miss it you are listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
alrighty so the reason that a lot of
people are not vaccinating according to
the left of course it's the right and
tucker carlson and all of that
but the real reason that nobody or a few
a bunch of people are not vaccinated
including a lot of people in blue states
is because institutional trust is down
now the left believes that the
institutions should be trusted no matter
what because institutions are more
important than actual human beings
this is why you will hear people like
anthony thatcher say if you contradict
me
it's because you don't believe in the
science the science
right it's like well no you're not the
science trademark
you are actually just a scientist and
apparently
very often a guy who makes mistakes
about that the institutional trust
problem continues unabated
you can't trot out andrew cuomo to kill
all the olds in new york and then also
try out andrew cuomo to be
your lead spokesperson on get the vax
you can't you can't do that it's just
not going to be effective
and yet that's exactly what's happening
so here was andrew cuomo yesterday
explaining that you should get
vaccinated which by the way
i agree with but when andrew cuomo says
it i'm like i'm not
sure i believe that you are the proper
spokesperson
for this especially when you say things
like this right andrew cuomo
who lied about like half a dozen things
in in his state
he says i've told you the truth since
day one hmm
i have told you the facts on covid
from day one whether they were
easy whether they were hard i told
you the truth while a lot of people were
talking politics
and a lot of people were talking theory
and a lot of people were trying to deny
because they didn't want to deliver bad
news
i told you the truth you know why
because i believe in you
oh why won't people trust our
institutions
the man is still covering up how many
people died in nursing homes by
reclassifying people who got sick in
nursing homes and lived in nursing homes
as not dying in nursing homes if they
died in a hospital meanwhile you've got
jen saki over at the white house she was
asked specifically you know there are
some people who are infected at the
white house by the texas democrats who
showed up
on their doorstep by the way i am amused
the texas democrats
are um now doing like gofundme
fundraisers
for ramen or something it's like i'm
pretty sure they can afford that like do
they have credit cards how does that
work in any case
apparently they infected a bunch of
democrats in the white house and jensaki
was asked who in the white house has a
covet infection
here was her answer has the white house
had any additional
staffers test positive for coping 19 i
think again our policy just to reiterate
it which we announced last week
is that if there's an individual who is
has close proximity to any of the four
principles as defined by the white house
medical unit in line with cdc guidelines
on what that looks like
we will then make that information
available and immediately public to all
of you
so that has not been the case since we
announced that policy no
uh so i'm supposed to trust you guys
about like covid vaccinations and
coveted infections and you won't even
say who in the white house has coveted
and by the way this was not the rule
during the trump administration if a
low-level trump administration official
got coveted
and it was like okay that was big
national news meanwhile joe biden gets
irritated
by even being asked questions so
yesterday there was an announcement from
the veterans administration
that if you work in a va hospital
they're going to mandate that you get
vaccinated which actually i got to say i
don't think is like the world's worst
policy
again if you're working in a hospital
you're literally working with people who
are ill and have serious preexisting
conditions
every single day many of whom can't get
vaccinated so that's a different
situation than you're working a bus
at the mta okay but that's not really
the point the point here is that joe
biden gets angry when people ask him
questions
the first rule by the way of of
convincing people to believe you as an
authority figure is explaining yourself
jeremiah never wants to explain himself
because he's sort of an old crotchety
dude
who believes that everybody should just
believe what he has to say
veterans are such a pain in the neck but
i'm gonna answer your question because
you've known each other for so long it's
nothing to do with iraq
the answer no no i'll answer your
question
yes veteran affairs is going to in fact
require
that all docs working in that and
facilities
are going to have to be vaccinated yeah
you're such a pain in the neck you're a
pain in the neck if you ask questions to
joe biden you're a pain in the neck
jensaki
yesterday she suggested that we're going
to continue to keep travel bans in place
from various places on earth
despite the fact that it's not working
right the delta variance is already
widely seated in the united states there
is no data to suggest that preventing
travel from europe to the united states
is going to cut down
on the number of infections in the
united states considering that the delta
variants is running roughshod
through the population that is
unvaccinated but here she is again
proposing policies that don't make sense
given where we are today and i think
you've seen this and those of you have
asked we've confirmed this for
with the delta variant we will maintain
existing travel restrictions at this
point for a few reasons
the more transmissible delta variant is
spreading both here and around the world
driven by the delta variant cases are
rising here at home particularly among
those who are unvaccinated
and appear likely to continue in the
weeks ahead
okay maybe the reason why people don't
trust any of these authority figures
is because these authority figures have
not earned the trust of the american
people
by the way there's a bipartisan failure
here if you don't explain your policy
and you don't do it clearly and
concisely and you don't take seriously
concerns
nobody is going to pay attention to you
and
instead the move of the left is to
browbeat and i think there there's a
specific political reason for that
because if you browbeat then you can
treat anybody who doesn't listen as an
enemy
instead of trying to convince people to
do the things you think they should do
instead you just yell at them and you
don't explain things to them and then
when they don't do it you say ah you are
the problem you're the problem
for example last night on cnn you had
ellison
camerata and she was grilling the mayor
of a
of a missouri town on why he opposed a
mass mandate now the reason to oppose a
mass mandate at this point
for the vaccinated is because the
vaccinated are vaccinated
okay and and the idea that we are going
to force people who are vaccinated to
mask up to protect the unvaccinated who
have had every opportunity to go get the
vaccine
and still have the opportunity to go
back get the vaccine the data to support
a mass mandate on the vaccinated
is really really weak at best and it is
a serious violation of freedom for
people who did the thing that you
they were supposed to do but here are
the hosts of cnn alison cameron and
victor blackwell
trying to browbeat the the wildwood
mayor jim balon saying
you know you need a mass man you need it
right now please explain
why you think that a mask mandate is
necessary from the government at this
time
seriously they won't they'll just
browbeat them
i just want to give people a status
report of where your county is
um hospitalizations are up the number of
people in icus are up
the number of people on ventilators are
up so why not
make people wear masks indoors
for a little while until you get the
numbers down
let me ask you and i i don't mean this
to be insulting but we've had some
people who have been against local
mass mandates answer this question in a
way that would lead us in a different
part of the
conversation do you believe that masks
work
to block and mitigate the virus people
are
dying in st louis county they're on
ventilators they're in the hospital
and so if you don't believe in mass
mandates and you don't believe in
vaccine mandates
then how are you going to get out of
this
okay so that is not journalism at this
point this is just brow beating by the
way i'm looking
right now at st louis county the number
of deaths the seven day rolling average
in st louis county of death is according
to the new york times
one that is the seven day rolling
average in st louis county what you get
from cnn is people are dying
everyone's saying by the way this guy's
answer was actually quite good right his
answer was
if the standard is now going to be that
every time there's an uptick in kovid
and without vaccinations and so forth it
stays around in perpetuity
presumably we will be doing masks in
perpetuity forever he is correct
emergency authority is to be used when
there's an emergency and if you prolong
the emergency
by suggesting that people who don't do
what you say are the emergency you have
now created
the impetus to cram down whatever you
want for all time and the left is in
love with this you're going to see them
do this on global warming
you're going to see them do this on
quote unquote income inequality you're
going to see them do this with regards
to the quote-unquote racial reckoning
everything is an emergency and if it's
an emergency you require emergency
powers and the emergency
can never end because any if anyone
opposes you their mere presence on the
world stage
is the emergency even if the
externalities no longer exist because
everyone has the ability to get a
vaccine if you're an adult
hey this is a power grab pure and simple
it is scary and it should frighten
anybody who gives a damn about
baseline freedom in the united states
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later today with an additional hour of
content plus
remember tonight we are doing a live
signing over at dailywire.com so become
a member and also
buy a copy of my brand new book and when
you do when you go over to daily
wire.com and you buy a signed copy of my
book you can ask a question maybe we'll
answer it for you tonight during the
live book signing also coming up soon
the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show
morning wire on today's show the justice
department decides not to investigate
nursing home deaths in 2020
house democrats assemble a january 6th
committee and tensions rise as u.s
diplomats sit down with chinese
officials
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with
our show morning wire